Mission comes out too
zero okay well it can't be zero Kevin I
entered the sale and I hit enter and I
said
I'm pretty sure I timesed it right you
met your commission cap last week so
from here until the end of the fiscal
year your commission will be zero what
are you talking about we we have a
commission cap it's a new corporate
policy
is this job really about the money for
you Jim I mean isn't this where you fell
in love a commission cap takes away my
incentive to sell so you realize I now
have no reason to work right well since
I have no incentive to sell I've cleaned
my car organized my desk and taken a
multivitamin so
what now
okay now I've tried everything did you
prank Dwight
you like that yeah yeah it's not as fun
if I'm not blowing off work I love you
but kind of busy so I need you to figure
this
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh nice wasting time here we go hey back
off it's solitaire
a kid
here you're looking for work talk to me
how far can you reach those lovely long
arms here's
yeah but no how long can you hold that
pretty little breath of yours
good
hey Jim
are you distracting these people we're
working
can you at least try to look busy
my name is Jack Griffin
and I don't want to be here
I am an award-winning philosophy scholar
who for reasons I won't go into finds
himself with a free year so I'm living
in my dead Mom's apartment here in
Toledo while killing a little bit of
time teaching
advanced placement biology
but here's the deal I do not care about
biology we're not going to do any
biology in here and to be perfectly
clear this won't be one of those things
where over the course of a year I
secretly teach it to you this also won't
be one of those things where I end up
learning more from you than you do for
me I know more than all of you combined
so that doesn't make any sense I'm going
to spend the majority of my time
mentally breaking my Nemesis with the
ultimate goal of taking his job as the
head of Stanford philosophy and then
we're going to have sex with as many
women as I possibly can throughout the
entire State of California
but you don't need to concern yourselves
with that sorry
if you guys have some filing holy crap
this is going to take all day yeah
yeah and all day
all day with that that was a two dare
okay well hand me some files
you're not gonna bother actually walking
why should we you can work from down
here I'm sitting down as long as I can
I'm not getting out of the chair until
it's time to go home oh typical standing
Elite you couldn't sit all day if you
tried what you don't think I could
Outlast you turds in a chair honey you
don't have to ask for it
let's talk terms both cheeks on the
cushion at all times obviously bathroom
breaks two and a half minutes every
three hours but you gotta roll the chair
fully into the stall obviously
okay
let's do this welcome to the butler
bricks
oh I spoke to Internal Affairs and since
Hitchcock and Scully did steal that
money even though it was to help someone
there have to be consequences
one year of desk Duty yeah oh I mean oh
no nice job on the water fountain it
wasn't me don't deny it I know it wasn't
the nurse I'm asking you to step up not
replacing Leslie just picking up some
slack I don't want to do things I want
to not do things just like you taught me
wow 12 15 you're early today April
there's no paper in the printer so
so that's the one thing you do
attention April stop doing that Jerry
told me to so it's super crucial more
important than that and more important
than anything in this godforsaken world
is finding me an assistant
I want to be your assistant really
you hate it here so do you
I'll make sure you don't have to go to
any meetings
if anyone comes to see you I'll scare
them away
wait April if you had to choose between
these two ties
where are you going I want to talk to
Ryan about the size of my desk
schedule an appointment
how about now Ron's not here he's right
there I I can see him
I'll let you know when he's available
attention shoppers Cloud9 brand tablets
are half off the Halo fog has a HD
display and boasts a battery life of
about 45 minutes hey I need you to work
the register while Tim's in the bathroom
no I don't do registers look I know that
it's really the hip thing for you
Millennials to not give a crap that's
not true and we're the same age but
please go on it's all hands on deck so
quit your minds facing and get on the
register that's an order
all right let me just finish this
announcement fine but the second you're
done I want you on register three
the second I'm down
you can also view thousands of movies on
the Halo fall
I will now list some of the movies that
are probably on there Mrs Doubtfire
Silence of the Lambs that one where
Nicholas Cage switches faces and says
he's going to eat a peach for hours oh
Forrest Gump that's a good movie and
then Jenny
dies of what is implied to be AIDS but
we don't know and he puts Haley Joel
Osmond on a bus and guess what same bus
driver from the beginning what are you
still doing here you're supposed to be
on the register you said I could finish
the announcement yeah that was 10
minutes ago it's a very long
announcement
next up Apollo 13. I see what you're
doing here in this film Tom Hanks is a
space man whose life is saved by a bunch
of nerds I've been studying Michael for
years and I've condensed what I've
learned into this chart
how Michael spends his time as you can
see we are procrastinating and
distracting others and this tiny sliver
here is critical thinking
I made it bigger so that you could see
it
Thunder Mifflin this is Pam
Pam oh hi Jan
he's uh
by Jan
[Music]
ET
I still have the lease on the Michael
Scott paper company so occasionally I
will sneak out here for a little coffee
and dancing
I actually Dance all the time
tiptoeing around corporate it is a
ballet when I am Breaking All the Rules
I'm break dancing and
expresso
[Music]
all right